then sex burn your art upstairs our fan  if he pick it easy it's the annual  renewal of a centuries-old tradition  Munich's mayor Christian odor taps the  first oktoberfest keg the first beer  went to Bavarian State premier Horst  Seehofer this year aletta will set back  visitors 10 euros but the steep prices  haven't dampened spirits for the next  three weeks the beer tents will be  filled to overflowing with partygoers  from around the world locals and  tourists alike dressed for the occasion  in the traditional Bavarian dentals and  lederhosen Munich is a top tourist  destination in Germany and Oktoberfest  is an unrivaled attraction an estimated  six million people will visit before the  world's biggest beer bash ends on  october sixth